yes guys Rico Verhoeven hier
we zijn hier in Halsteren
waar ik 1 heel mooi initiatief Ben gestart
en zo'n initiatief
start je niet alleen
en daar HEB je hulp bij nodig van partners
en 1 van die partners
was keukenconcurrent en die heeft ons geholpen
met het plaatsen van 2
prachtige keukens
yes dit is het eindresultaat
wauw fantastisch
het is zo ontzettend mooi geworden
1 hele hoop professionals die echt weten
hoe ze te werk moeten gaan met jongeren
die uit huis geplaatst zijn
die misschien lichamelijke en mentale problemen hebben
1 van De Dingen die ik daar
wel heel belangrijk in vind
is lichamelijke beweging en voeding natuurlijk omdat
voeding doet zoveel met je
zeker weet ik dat als sporter en als atleet zijnde
dus 1 stukje voeding gezond en lekker eten
en dat kan je natuurlijk alleen maar
in 1 hele goeie en fijne keuken klaarmaken
en die hebben ze gekregen
dus keukenconcurrent
bij deze namens mij en alvast namens de jongeren
dank jullie wel voor deze samenwerking
want we zijn hier echt ontzettend
blij mee en dankbaar voor